-You are obviously
very accomplished.
Your sister
is a climate scientist.
-She is.
-Which is a very cool job
and one we need more of.
-Yeah, she's amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And she was invited --
this is her right here...
-That's her.
-...to be a guest
at Michelle Obama's...
-At the State of the Union.
-...at Obama's State of
the Union by Michelle Obama.
-Yeah, Michelle --
she was Michelle Obama's guest.
Yeah, she's --
she works particularly
with, like, you know,
how climate change affects
low-income and Latino
communities and people of color
'cause they're
disproportionately affected
by the things --
there's no infrastructure.
So she goes around the --
around the country talking
and -- and, you know, educating
people about what's going on.
She's incredible.
She really stole my thunder.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That -- That is --
-I was going to ask.
-Yeah.
-'Cause if you -- yeah.
-Deservedly --
-Nicole Hernandez Hammer --
that's her name --
Nicole Hernandez Hammer.
-Have you --
Have you ever been invited
to the State of the Union?
-No.
Ever met --
have you met the Obamas?
-Maybe this year.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
-Met the Obamas?
-No, but I met Malia.
-Okay. That counts, yeah.
-Yes, yes, yes.
She was -- 'cause she's --
She was doing an internship
at a costume facility.
-Okay.
-And I -- And I was there.
-And I remember I walked by her
like I knew her.
I was like -- 'cause I thought
she was someone that I knew.
And I was like, "Ah, I can't
remember where I know her from."
I was like, "Oh,
that's where I know her from."
[ Laughter ]
And I came back out.
And I even said, "Sorry.
I kind of acted
like I knew you already."
She was like, "No, I know."
She was like,
"But, you know, my dad
really loved 'Ex Machina.'"
-Wow!
-I said, "Really? Wow. Cool."
-That's a good thing to hear.
I like that movie, too.
-Yeah, yeah.
-He and I are very similar.
-Yeah, you guys are...
[ Laughter ]
-Intellectually.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I think we're, like,
very intellectual.
The same tastes and stuff.
-I can tell, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You finished -- You finished
filming the ninth "Star Wars."
That's done?
-All done, yes.
-How very exciting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, finished.
-Are you --
I'm just curious because,
you know, obviously,
those films
are very intense and --
and there are giant budgets,
and there's
an expectation for them.
What do you -- When you're,
like, in between shooting,
what are you doing to --
to stay calm
or -- or to --
to just relax?
-In between shooting --
you know, I don't know.
There's -- It's funny
'cause you -- you do get --
like,
we're such adaptable creatures
that even the craziest
of situations
start to feel so routine.
-Sure.
-You know?
It's like,
"I got to squeeze back in
this Millennium Falcon again."
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "This is not made
for ethnic people."
This is -- Solo had very
slender hips, didn't he?
So, you know, it's funny.
You know, but -- but
by the end of it, it really was,
like, the emotion of the whole
thing finally being over.
-Yeah.
-You know?
And that --
that was just unbelievable.
I mean,
not only these three movies,
but the whole Skywalker saga.
-It's crazy.
Yeah, an amazing thing.
I'm so happy
you ended up being a part of it.
It was fantastic. And it's
always so great to see you.
-Yeah, good to see you, too.
-Thank you for coming back.
Really appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]